You know guys the term 200 IQ is reserved for a very special type of play
when it comes to League of Legends.
I'm Colin for theScore esports and this week, we went back to school to give you the
Top 10 200 IQ Plays in League.
Now for this list guys bear in mind,
we're not talking about mechanical outplays here. Faker-Ryu might have been legendary, but at the end of the day
came down to raw skill.
For this list we're looking at those more cerebral big brain outplays.
So let's get on with it with the Top 10 200 IQ Plays from League of Legends.
Starting off our list at Number 10 is Soaz’s impressive play against SKT.
Origen were certainly the underdogs in their 2015 World Championship semifinal match against the Korean
dynasty and needed every edge they could get.
Soaz found himself in a tight spot after a gank from Bengi but was able to make a dazzling escape
thanks to some incredibly quick thinking and perfect timing.
(Casting)
At Number 9 we have Cloud 9’s Impact, who looked to be in a tough spot
after using most of his abilities to avoid a 2v1 gank from I May. With only a third of his health left,
Impact managed to flash to the safety of his turret.
What happened next was proof of the Korean top laner’s 200 IQ
as a perfectly placed equalizer allowed him to turn the tables on his opponents.
(Casting)
Coming in at Number 8 is Exileh’s timely ultimate during the Summer Split Quarterfinals against Giants.
With a comfortable lead in Game 1, the Unicorns of Love were looking to secure Baron.
But Giants had other plans and attempted to quickly rush the Baron pit.
Veritas’ Ashe and Hylisang’s Braum helped keep Giants out of the pit long enough for Move to secure the Baron,
but it was Exileh’s perfectly timed ultimate that allowed the Unicorns to escape with their lives.
(Casting)
Making its way in at Number 7 is G2’s exceptional teamplay against Fnatic.
Faced with a 3v5 situation, it looked like G2 had no way of fending off Fnatic’s 5-man push.
But Perkz managed to turn the tides of the fight
that started with a perfectly placed miasma to punish Jesiz’s forward positioning
and push caps out of the front line.
(Casting)
Between Perkz’s instant flash onto mithy’s lantern,
and his last-second heal from twin fangs and dangerous game mastery,
G2 managed to walk away with two kills, only losing Expect at the very end of the fight.
While our Number 6 play may not seem like much from the outset, when dealing with genius
there is always more than meets the eye.
Rox had just lost their top laner but noticed an opening after two Afreeca players returned
to the fountain and took the chance to start the Baron.
Spirit attempted to get into position to steal the Baron from Rox, but Key had other plans
as he pathed in between Spirit and the Baron, catching the sonic wave and holding onto his
flash for just the right moment.
(Casting)
If Key  flashes any sooner, there’s a chance Spirit
doesn’t use his dash.
Any later and Spirit would end up in the Baron pit in perfect position to attempt the baron steal.
Simply put, this 200 IQ timing secured Rox the Baron.
The Number 5 play on our list sees Phoenix 1’s Arrow set up his team
for a successful teamfight against Team liquid.
As Xpecial locks down the enemy Braum, Arrow seizes the opportunity to hit multiple carries,
dodging everything Team Liquid throws at him before cleansing the CC with Mercurial Scimitar
and flashing back behind his team.
(Casting)
Because of their positioning and low HP TL couldn’t follow up on the Glacial Fissure
which lead to Phoenix 1 decimating their tanks.
Coming in at Number 4 is SKT setting up an impeccable teamfight in Game 3
of the 2017 Mid-Season Invitational finals.
Taking on G2, Bang sets up a wall of traps that forced the enemy towards the bottom side of mid lane
while Peanut positioned himself at the top of the lane,
drawing G2’s frontline towards him.
With all of their carries on the bottom side of the lane Wolf flashes to the wall,
hits a three man grasping root and follows it up with a stranglethorn.
(Casting)
With all of the team fight threats held down,
SKT takeover this fight and ace G2 on their way to defending their MSI title.
Coming in at 3 is a play from the fabled Telecom Wars
that’s unlike any other on our list as it features a number of 200 IQ decisions.
Following a picture-perfect teamfight, SKT had to decide where to send their players.
KT’s super minions were beginning to siege their nexus turrets,
the Baron was up, and they had a large wave pushing KT’s mid lane inhibitor turret.
The team tasked Wolf and Huni with defending their nexus while the rest of SKT went to push mid.
Huni then teleported to the last surviving minon to help keep SKT’s push alive at the cost of both nexus turrets.
(Casting)
It proved to be worth it as SKT managed to secure baron,
and win a 5v4 fight under their exposed nexus to secure the win.
(Casting)
Our Number 2 play sees SKT against the ropes in Game 2 of their semifinal matchup against The Rox Tigers.
Rox looked to close the game out with PraY and GorillA’s
exceptional pushing ability and managed to take the top inhibitor while Peanut bought them time in the bot lane.
Once they had cracked the base, PraY delivered an insane cross map arrow that stopped Duke’s teleport,
and sealed the game.
(Casting)
With SKT’s return to base staggered and Smeb teleporting in,
the ROX trio had all but secured the win.
(Casting)
Coming in at the coveted number one spot is a Fnatic squad
that looked all but finished against SK Gaming at IEM Katowice 2013.
They had super minions knocking on their nexus’ door and had just lost a teamfight in SK’s base
that appeared to be the finishing blow. But xPeke had other plans.
After escaping the fight with his life, the legendary mid laner hid in the topside jungle,
waiting for SK to enter his base.
Once they do he teleports back into SK’s base, and the rest quite literally is history.
(Casting)
Well guys I don't know about you, but I feel smarter already.
But if any of you braniacs do disagree with our Top 10 list.
Well, let me know in the comments, and I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.